哇不得了
台湖股今天開高走低快1000點
我今天要告訴你三大重點
為什麼開高走低快1000點
第二個
重點是外資大逃殺
今天外資應該是超大幅度的賣超
因為台幣大扁1.4角
算這幾個月來的新低
代表外資大逃殺
為什麼所謂合適呢
第三件事情
7月還能52000呢
很多人說
投資產這邊怪怪的
會真的很怪嗎
可是為什麼我們的股票這麼強
為什麼我們的環球金精彩
今天都可以摸到展停板
為什麼台股灣股市
好像看起來有點強中透落
我的股票為什麼這麼強呢
今天我獨家報告
這一切的標果秘密
台股大盤今天有點開高走低
但是投資長的股票
沒有最標
只有更標
投資長上週五在節目上
特地預告大家
好戲登場的精彩
萬事俱備
只欠東風
茶一根就要全面噴出了
果然今天一早
金材直接跳空喷出
一度锁上涨停
还有环球晶今天出关第一天
也是直接喷上涨停
大盘今天开高走低
正幅将近千点
投资朋友们都很担心
是因为受到日韩股影响
还是另有其因呢
你想知道更多股市八卦吗
手上还没有标股吗
接下来就交给我们
经济日报选股冠军
单季188%的记录保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
國哲榮投資長
投資長好
莉莉 各位同學們大家好
你好 大家你好
不好意思 不好意思
讓大家 讓莉莉
練那麼長 我漏漏騰
這麼長的稱呼
也絕非我所願
可是不好意思
因為紙紙就這麼紅
沒錯
我已經少念
我們今天莉莉已經少念很多頭銜
已經刪很多了
刪很多了
來
來看一下
今天台灣股市開高走低快1000點
所謂何事
你看一下
這個怪怪的啦
是不是這樣說
殺下去 拉下去 殺下去
而且最後46,556點
可是我有沒有跟大家講過
我那時候很多人說
哲哲有沒有可能像這邊的行情一樣
直接給你V下去
有沒有
是不是直接V下去
等一下
看一個
直接V下去
直接V上去
說不對啦
這樣V啦
是不是
哲哲有沒有可能直接V
我說不可能啦
你看你現在在這邊晃啊是不是
再上去也不算直接VR
對不對
可是現在大事不妙
台幣有貶呢
很多人在說
可不可以每天紅K上去啊
我說沒有辦法
我說蘋果的一個利空
記憶體斬價害兇嘛
在抱怨他嘛對不對
對
記憶體斬價的利空
他在抱怨
那我說這個利空要怎麼樣
吸收一陣子
幸好蘋果上禮拜五
怎麼樣
大展作收
上禮拜四大展作收
等於換句話說
這個利空
它已經吸收完畢了
就是我說的一到兩個禮拜
可是又傳出什麼
傳出說 哇 記憶體喔
有人說不缺了
是
中國大廠說記憶體不缺了
幸好啊
禮拜五怎麼樣
禮拜五傳出三星電子
第三季斬價潮要漲很多啊
漲20%啦
然後Metflash漲更多啦
所以我也不知道
為什麼今天群年
還沒可以拉暫停啊
可是就現在表現像什麼樣子
一堆利空
然后幸好有另外一个利多来救他
另外一个歧视来救他
现在最尴尬的是什么
又有一个新的利空
现在感觉很多的外资撤出亚洲股市
这是最麻烦的利空
现在记忆体还在怀疑论
AI也在怀疑论
你知道吗
AI在怀疑论
所以大家会觉得说
这怎么会这样子
我们来看一下
看一下
看一下这个台币的一个贬值
这往上去是贬值
没错吧
你们自己看一下
这本来之前是31.2
换一个新台币
现在变32元
有没有看到
有
台币贬值
有没有看到
最简单的你看一下
来看一下
00662嘛
是不是
纳斯达克ETF
你看今天就小幅了
涨一点点
有没有看到
这台币贬值
应该涨更多啦
还有00687B是不是
已經很久忘記這個美債了
讓我放很久的美債
再次重申
美債只有折受傷
如果你美債受傷
代表你不是折粉
因為那個時間
你換台灣50的話
基本上應該都大賺了
好不好
OK嗎
好
所以你看
為什麼美債跟0062
這種納斯達克ETF會漲
最主要原因是
因為怎麼樣
你換成美金了
你知道嗎
你把台幣它換成
它會換成美金
買美金資產
台幣貶的
相對於美金資產就漲
好
來看一下
最尷尬的是你不知道外資的企圖是什麼
你看扁成這樣子有沒有看到
那當然現在賞戶感覺
買進的力道已經有點歷竭了
我在考慮是不是很多人在想說
是不是該買都進來了
阿嬤都進來了
已經變全民運動了
插鞋筒都變成插鞋筒了
所以現在資金潮不夠有力
不夠有力好不好
這跟大家講
然後現在都跑到一些小型股
比如說24814
強暴政這些股票
你要搞清楚
現在二級體很紅對不對
可是你們要搞清楚一件事
這些股票股本非常小
股本很小
是呀 你給我看一下這些股本
跟被動員建議比較一下
股本 然後市值一樣
好不好
這就是為什麼我不去PON這些股票的原因
一來這個已經拉上去了
二來這個股本真的有點小
我知道現在很多人在喊
那股本 現在是有量
等到台股沒有量的時候
這些你就危險了
你要記住這些東西
有好有壞啦 有好有壞
我不要扯遠了
扯遠好像變成攻擊個股或攻擊人家
來 我是要告訴你說
台灣的資金現在是不是有點退潮
是內資感覺怎麼樣
後繼無力
散戶現在後繼無力已經太有錢了
外資在落跑
所以你要觀察新台幣不能再貶
新台幣貶成這樣是不對的
當然這幾年來說
新台幣貶台灣股市還是一直漲
像今天說老實話
以前扁那麼兇基本上要大跌了
你知道嗎 你看
他已經扁到一個4月來一個低點
有沒有看到
3月那時候有沒有看到 3月底有沒有看到
3月底的時候
我們在說這個應該是我們看一下
3月的時候
你自己看台光股市3月的時候
應該是這邊
應該這邊有沒有看到
台幣那時候扁應該是這邊有沒有看到
那時候3萬4有沒有很懷念
然後現在台幣
現在漲到4萬6 4萬7的有沒有
是
從3萬4漲到4萬7
現在可是台幣已經回到3萬4這個地方
代表外資都整個落跑了
外資現在不相信亞洲股市
覺得亞洲股市漲太多
這是隱憂 一定要觀察
當然幸好我們有萬能的內資
萬能的賞戶全部站起來
好不好 我只告訴你
在這邊 來來
來
所以我要講的是說
現在還有能救台股
還有下禮拜的台積電法說會
我等一下一起跟大家講
我們來先點點名
來大家台股來點點名
來來來
中美機怎麼沒有噴上去
中美金啊
不要寫錯好不好
要嘛中美機要嘛中美金
好不好
來
開高走低
是不是台幣冷的貨
來按讚喔
現在我們是唯一百萬的粉絲
唯一百萬粉絲
好不好
今天值得分數還好
一開始就這樣子
差不多到最後應該
就應該4500到5000多的一個中間
按照平常習慣
好 來 我們來看一下
第四法人買氣力量弱
職壓利率提高
對
現在職壓利率提高有差
對 政府在收縮資金
難怪你這樣講沒錯
所以你現在變成
為什麼台灣股市
所以你現在整個反問我說
7月5萬2 5萬3有沒有機會
說有
可是因為現在各大券商
再怎麼樣
把錢給收緊
就像股市一樣
就像房地產
你知道房地產為什麼說
活不下去嗎
新清安政策
自有新清安政策
大家可以借錢來買房子
後來沒有了
然後房地產就冷掉了
那你說股市會不會因為這樣冷
可是不會
因為股市比房地產好賺很多啦
我之前看過什麼天母的豪宅
怎麼樣放了11年賠2000多塊
現在房子是負資產
就是以前買房子是
可以住著 住一住
然後又賺到又換一個新的豪宅
你能不能懂
現在不是喔
你看地保的價格都下來了喔
是不是
地板價格的下你們知道
所以很多的價格下
就是你除非知道自住
你懂不懂
自住
養誰養誰的
或怎麼樣
或給家人住的
不然現在大家
沒有人想要做
反地產投資
好
那股市會變成
像反地產那麼慘嗎
不會
因為股市的錢還是很好賺
只是像質壓
剛才有人提到重點
質壓利率4%有關係
雖然我們的散戶
是在我的教育下
應該借錢不多
但我認為還是有人會借錢
或者有人知道這些消息
好不好
OK
哲哲你好 我是投資小白
小心詢問 如果是美院固定買ETF
會推薦0050還是VOO
我覺得0050比較好 好不好
VOO也是不錯 好不好
只是VOO的話
你可能就不會看我節目了 好不好
OK吧
0050就好了啦
0050就好了 好不好
我不要先買台灣的再買國外的
不然就一個一半了
今天哲哲很平靜 沒有人激動
你們一定要比我激動嗎
我現在已經有分身了
陳彥老師
我剛才有說叫他激動一點
他就是年輕時候的我了
他現在很激動
他連髮型都像我了
好不好
有一點
有一點對不對
你不覺得髮型很像我嗎
小孩你不覺得嗎
我自己像
他覺得他跟理髮師這樣講
我跟你講沒關係啦
所以你可以激動派
也請找陳彥老師好不好
謝謝陳彥老師
只是年紀大了
雖然我年紀好像應該沒有比他大
應該啦
來來
這個沒關係
幫他打廣告一下
沒有平靜沒有很激動
沒有啦
不要每天要我激動啦
好啦 我會激動一下啦 好不好
來 節目最專業了
來
來來 記憶體還可以報索
記憶體可以
可是記憶體感覺
最好賺的已經走了
你懂嗎
就是我覺得再來一次500元
我想要不要走
你懂嗎 好不好
然後這個你看 因為什麼
因為他願意漲價耶 你知道嗎
納科給你殺尾盤也不對
829群群群年
你最後給我殺下去
你去衝一下命
真的是莫名其妙
基體還是可以好不好
我們看一下基體
利基地
全部的基體開高走低
不應該全部
滑板電也是一樣
旺宏
只有旺宏最強而已好不好
好不好
旺宏
看起來旺宏也是沒在動了好不好
所以感覺基體最好賺的已經走了
那我也跟大家講
來我給你一個東西
展太多的股票
你要設一個停利點
譬如南亞科這一個低點
你就不能再破了
我認為啦 好不好
破的話我可能自己也會有一個行為
那就一定賣嗎
有時候我是民事有時候暗示
有時候講不清楚
我不一定要跟你講
就像你看年發科我現在怎麼樣
我在4000以下這邊出掉
同學也沒錯啊
我有出在4000多
4300也有
你自己看我出的績效
看一下
這都實在績效
而且我只秀普通會員的
年八科 你看我出在多少4270元對 莉莉就提醒我一下是我這個人 我比較不拘小潔
我現在比如台積電
有沒有看到
我跟五蝦米有沒有看到
死板本已過期
要買
蠻節儉的
沒問題
我寧願捐救護車
五蝦米我都用免費訂閱制
就提醒我
錄完影提醒我
趕快下載他一下
為什麼要查這東西
來
我忘記了
連發科4270
就是我的
我都念資在資
過期很久
怎麼樣
頒大家賺錢
好不好
要捐救護車
我希望大家像我一樣
同股之中
賺到錢以後怎麼樣
去捐個救護車
好不好
這個都有寫了
這則則第二台救護車
最新的
115年6月16日
有沒有看到
上個月的事情
桃園市政府
有沒有
因為它好像有一些我私人資料
郭忠先生
我們捐贈糾索一輛
一輛有沒有看到
一輛喔
好不好
就跟大家講
這是掃描的
希望大家像我一樣
來
來 我們看一下
我們來看一下
來來來看一下
所以等一下台積電法說
你再提醒我一下
好
所以這個也是
連發科也是一樣
剛才有4300日
我們4300出掉日
我看一下4300
對啊
4,270有沒有看到
4,270跟3,800
平均值也是吃在4,000塊以上
是不是沒錯吧
所以先出再說
先出就
我們
我們記憶體有很多也賺很多
有沒有看到
記憶體這邊也賺很多
記憶體環球金
環球金賺150%很誇張
今天
150%我還沒走
破紀錄了
好像破紀錄
有了有了
好像年發科最多好像到160、170
哎呦 167 我記得啊
星星啊 星星王王賺160幾%啊
星星去年被人家罵得要死啊
就後來賺那麼多啦
南亞科你看85%
所以南亞科到時候破一個底我就會走
好不好 因為機體實在是
要上去也有理由
要跌也有理由 你知道嗎
可是台灣股市今天有點多跌了
我覺得台灣股市今天是被挫殺
因為開高會外資落跑
因為禮拜五美股沒有開盤
那台灣股市就像我講的
像職壓利率都在縮減
都在縮減資金你知道嗎
現在券商已經快沒錢了
不能說快沒錢
就是它利用那種
對 有一些快沒錢的
或有些利用就是職壓政策
慢慢的縮減大家的資金
那你就說你要借沒關係
4% 5%
你還得起沒關係
就算你倒債也沒關係
就是我賺你的利息賺飽飽
你懂我意思嗎
那也是一般的政府
可能政府的政策
就是什麼
因為高的職壓利率
来降低你去借的一个风险
也是借的风险
以价质量你知道吗
以价质量
就像有些人
也比较喜欢去高级的餐厅
你知道怎么样吗
人会比较少一点点
但是现在台湾人很有钱
你看吃到饱
想A就一
想一想
人都很多
可是一般的高级餐厅
再高级一点的话
平均大概四五千块单客的话
其实会蛮好记的
蠻好定位的啦
我台北市蠻好定位的
其實我跟你講
我是扯遠的
我只跟你講
去了很多吃日本以後
我發現其實日本食物
沒有以前那麼好吃
你知道嗎
而且很容易被宰
真的真的
就是定價也不太同
我覺得台灣的食物
台灣的日式料理
還比日本的日式料理好吃
因為比較好找
日本的日式料理很多很深
如果你那麼深的話
那就還好
扯遠的 扯遠的 好不好
好啦 我說台灣人都是
以價制量嘛
對不對
我說我們吃比較高級的餐廳
客人就會比較少
那現在這個質壓利率也是一樣
所以現在錢有點上不去
我們看成交量
你看成交量現在都縮了
6000多億
縮很快 6000多億
6311億
最近的最低的
最低量
市場是不是最低量
優秀 滿低的
好久沒有低於照
對啊
這不是連發科
嚇死我
一兆了 我覺得奇怪怎麼沒有
沒有6000多億
一兆成這樣 對不起
對不起 剛才看錯
可是台灣股市成交量一兆啦
也是滿低的
你看近期的新低有沒有看到
量有在說有沒有看到
很明顯
一兆
就現在的一個市值而言
一兆成這樣算還好
政府在資金在壓縮好不好
OK
他機動會員的股票會飆
沒有 今天股票也是很飆啦
你們為什麼要逼我激動
對啊
我不要喔
我都會請人家幫我量那個血壓
你知道嗎
我很怕喔
因為我想跟你們長命百歲
我想要工作到80歲 90歲
我說真的
我很想要那個
就是我是看一次少一次
我說真的
隨時可能我不會公開
如果公開
我是說真的會珍惜
就是我會服務會員
以服務會員為主
你懂得意思嗎
就是我不需要去
一定要拋頭肉臉
所以你們看到我現在
也沒在辦演講了
然後也沒有那個
外面的那個
就是節目我也沒去接受
好不好 因為都太滿了
是跟大家講的
好不好 OK嗎
好
這來
想A就有一種公司上班過
我不喜歡
我喜歡不激動哲哲
好啦 我就激動好不好
到底要激動什麼
我也不知道為什麼
我現在比較不激動
好啦
你們這樣講好像很奇怪
講果票標股可以吧
精采夠不夠精采
很精彩啦 有沒有
超級精彩
環球晶
哲哲
環球晶今天也快暫停
可是哲哲你不是今天環球晶會殺下去
我先跟你們講個淡數
因為我以為禮拜五
台灣股市的這個很好笑
台灣股市這個證交所的這個策略
他是講一個區間
他沒有講說一定
怎麼樣情況下他一定會處置他
你聽懂嗎
上禮拜五創新高基本上要被處置對不對
是
要被警告對不對
是不是 沒錯吧
對
上禮拜五如果再被警告的話
今天就怎麼樣
就會整個被處置了
你聽懂嗎
說說上禮拜五被警告
今天被警告的話對不對
就會被處置了
可是上禮拜五剛好沒有被警告
沒有被警示
是
聽懂嗎
上禮拜五創新高怎麼不會被警示
你搞的你知道嗎
上禮拜五長那麼多怎麼會被警示
所以證交所上禮拜該警示
他沒有警示
我不是批評政府喔
我先跟他講
我不是批評證交所
這是個很難拿捏啦
所以我不是說處置完不錯
我看起來處置完也還好
因為重點是證交所在判斷
這個要不要被處置的時候
要不要被警示的時候
他不是名文寫著
怎麼樣的情況下
我一定處置你
基本上你聽懂嗎
不是每一個都名文寫著
聽懂嗎
很複雜
真的很複雜
只能說今天
如果今天再被處置
今天再被處置
今天再被警示
明天再被警示
後天被警示
就會怎麼樣
等一下 再亮說了
可能要在20分鐘或一小時一盤
是
聽懂嗎 好不好
是跟大家講
所以環球晶上禮拜沒有被警示
那大戶當然今天敢拉拉
因為至少我三天
我不要連續三天再被警示就好
聽懂嗎 被警告就好
聽懂嗎
所以今天就拉起來
環球晶就拉起來了 很興奮
好 等一下 我跟你講
你們看我興奮的
我先聽你唱歌好不好
好
讓我調整心態
等一下興奮一下好不好
我來變身模式好不好
你們是喜歡我興奮嗎
來來來
我們先說為你賺錢
從吳克群的為你寫詩
好不好
吳克群我蠻喜歡他的歌
因為我也有大舌頭
他也有大舌頭
開玩笑
來
為你賺錢
今天是幹什麼
今天是什麼的
小韓唱嗎
我唱
你唱
來來來
為你賺錢
為你堅持
為你等噴出那一日
精彩今天就調空漲停
投資賬嫌與之
為你賺錢
為你翻倍
為你充活力的極限
為你找出所有標股的賣點
最標的股都在投資賬手裡
有剛才聽到你那個聲音的極限了
在這邊
有一點
還沒有播音就是ㄍ到這邊剛剛好
好不好 我覺得沒關係
這已經算你最適的音域了
好不好
來來 精彩今天就跳功掌停
投掌先一指
哇 精彩漂亮不漂亮
精彩是什麼
你們看一下精彩
我們嗨沒關係
精彩雖然這樣有點開高走低
但是要噴出去的
有沒有看到
上禮拜我說
今天差點如果紅K的話
就是很漂亮的
我上禮拜怎麼畫呢
畫這樣子紅K
紅K 紅K
你自己看 至少差一坑
來來看一下我們之前的預告
大概對80%有啦
來 看一下喔
好不好
嗨嗨嗨嗨
來
要碰了
打麻將 自摸
來看一下
來
今天拉高千點
不是你想的這樣
來看一下喔
這差那一根嘛
這你看我很多股票
差那一根
再來喔
精彩不要變我預告喔
再一根是不是就很好看
這再一根就很追了
是
再跟著創新高是很漂亮
是不是看我的股票都差什麼
臨門一角
萬事俱備
只欠東風
東風來了
碰壺
真的喔 碰壺
打麻將就這樣子
不知道大家有沒有打過麻將
好不好 OK
來 先跟大家講
只是還好不常打
好
真的
尤其單分析之後更少打
因為每天都來投資
要刺激的
沒有
比麻將刺激100倍
股市很刺激
有時候動個一兩塊
我們的會員就差了幾千萬了
來 因為會員人數多
來 我們是不是說插一個根
有沒有看到
今天金彩就噴出去有沒有
碰有沒有看到
真的插一個根
只是一個是紅色 一個是黑色
有沒有看到
是
可預告前面
今天漲停
那金彩會大物邊拉邊出
我就不會
金彩已經是洗很久了
金彩就是要噴出去真的
所以你看金彩
我那時候做過金彩
我賺五六十%
我真的是覺得沒什麼意思
現在金彩賺77%有沒有看到
來來
先看金彩
金彩一根展停板
對不對
那時候才一兩百塊有沒有看到
一兩百塊203
然後249
有沒有看到
今天344元有沒有看到
恭喜3374
金彩
股價已經連四紅
今天跳空本展停
再創立即高
我們多次買進 最高已經大賺77%的
Lucky7
我們持續看好他
我選擇持股 獲利去霸
9.28分
7月6號今天
你們喔 賺77%
暫停的時候
就算最後沒有暫停
還是賺很多啊
還是賺60%70%啊
是
是投資票人居然沒找到這麼好的分析師啊
精彩根本就送分給你
你很多股票你都吃我豆腐啊我也不在乎 你知道什麼嗎很多人 譬如說我精彩對不對我足足這樣賺一段一年百塊在那邊買我賺這一段很多人是這邊才買
你賺個10%幹嘛
你聽懂嗎
再講一次
很多人這樣子
吃我豆腐
誰吃誰豆腐還不知道
我賺這一段
賺77%
是不是
是
你就這邊才買有什麼用
賺個20%要幹嘛
你賺個20%說實話
你不能買台灣50
好不好
這邊行情就是這樣子
所以我要講一件結論是說
現在行情7月52000
取決於台積電的一個法說會
不然很難
那台積電法說會有沒有機會
有機會
所以台灣股市今年是
這個月是下半產決定
下半產決定
可是你看我的股票
那你就要選一些股票
不論台積電好不好
或者是台積電好
它會更飆的
那是什麼
不就這個精彩嗎
台積電資本支出概念股啊
是不是
台地人會不會再擴充
會不會再擴充資本
會不會再擴充資本之處
一定會嘛
雖然現在很多人抱怨
很多人都現在很多人都抱怨
龐蒂爾跟什麼
我之前是龐蒂爾的CO
跟那個還有誰
很多很多人都在抱怨
說太貴了
馬斯克也在抱怨
我的晶片記憶體都很貴
然後呢
So what
是不是
我們才賺這一次而已
該賺就是賺
可是問題是
現在的抱怨過程中
很多人覺得
會不會這樣的高的資本支出
不可持續
大家在賭這個不可持續
很多人覺得還會持續
你懂不懂
好
所以我覺得會有一個問題
所以最後台積電會怎麼樣
一錘定將三
告訴你答案是什麼
我們先來看台積電的法說
來看一下
台積電法說這邊已經有了
台積電全年展望
拼二度善修
莉莉啊 我真的是
我那时候是不是讲说
重点是不是美元营收
是不是要三四成以上
没错
需要播重播吗
不用 我已经预期了
这个头版新闻能不能到
是
台积电全年展望营修
拼二度散修
来 画面给我
那很简单吧
它怎么样
来 等一下
拼二度散修
我们来看一下这次新闻
現在有說4成
我跟你講如果美元營收拼4成
那不得了啦
不得了什麼意思
那等於是台積電的股價
也機會散修喔
你聽懂嗎
好 那有沒有機會4成
我就有機會
那我外資說
有人預估連增率到34到36
我覺得36就很高了
如果36他會說怎麼樣
法說會說
30到40的中位數
然後他之前是說
今年的營收超過30%
對不對
美元營收
就台積電的美元營收
年增率
就今年的年增率
比去年的年增率
高怎麼樣
畫面給我
去年年增率比去年年增率高
大概30%
那30%就超過30%一點點了
因為如果還會說
如果是35%的話
還會怎麼說
會說30%到40%的中階
中階或中位數
它用英文講
好不好
然後如果是35%到40%
他會說30到40的中高位階
聽懂嗎
是
所以代表是說
只要他講30到40的中階
或中高位階
代表是他營收真的上調
因為原本講超過而已
他超過30%代表
你沒有超過35
因為如果35
他會講他的30到40的中位數
台積電法說的定調都是這樣子
我獨家教你好不好
我獨家教你
所以我要告訴你
是說如果40%
40%當然有機會
為什麼有時間
我就要講
看到他們這樣漲價
他也想漲價啊 是不是
是
那記憶體這樣漲 為什麼不能這樣漲
OK啊 要漲一起漲啊
不然怎麼樣 你咬我啊
是不是
所以我覺得40%是有機會的
而且他不是說
只要先進製成都有漲價嗎
欸 我們他們台積電的技術含量
跟記憶體不一樣耶
你看到台積電什麼時候被人家這樣砍架過
沒有啊
可是記憶體常被人家砍架啊
所以記憶體的技術含量沒有那麼高啊
你知道啊
你看中國的產商可以在後面追
是不是
台灣台積電不是耶
把中國的產商甩到後面去耶
你聽懂嗎
這真的事實啊
台積電的技術還怎樣
不一樣啊 好不好 不一樣
所以這個就是舊台灣股市
所以我認為法說會之前
頂多法國社會前一兩天有人壓榜台股牆
法說會之前我覺得他就在混啦
盾啦 好不好
就沖一下 散去一下 散去一下 沖一下
要整個散去要等台積電法說
有沒有機會 有 所以你要先壓榜
台積電法說會
法晍電法說資本支出概念股你要先壓榜
有沒有 精彩
有沒有 我剛剛說77%
房宣者說 又開高就低
沒有關係嘛 剛創新高而已嘛 是不是
房宣在這邊沒什麼 也沒跌很兇
你在這邊拉滾你反而要做多
你還記得拉滾做多
我覺得政府 僅說大家的資金是好事
為什麼是好事
你每天都要借錢
一個股災就危險了啦 好不好
4%的利率你想借就隨便你借 好不好
至少你借也不會借那麼多
你懂不懂
有質壓率4% 你們也借得下去
不如用那個理財行
理財行房貸比較好
好不好
我說硬要比啦
我的觀念是全部都不要
OK嗎 為什麼全部都不要
很簡單啦
因為我不知道你是誰
每個人狀況不同
不要到時候扯到子澤身上
來來
就像我今天我跟你講一件事
你知道我本來
我是我們最東大樓的主委
我們公司在那個中上東路這邊附近
燕基街附近很漂亮的大樓
我本來想說
我們資金有一兩千萬
我本來想去查
我想說一兩千萬
很多就有些人或有些委員
想省錢 省錢
我說你幹嘛省錢
你為什麼不賺錢呢
那個多了一兩千萬
就是閒置資金一兩千萬
去買台灣五十教啦
這幾年一兩千萬
早就可以賺個四五千萬了對不對
沒錯吧
後來發現不行啊
法規規定不行啊
他說到時候會不會有背信啊
想想算了
做好人也沒有用好不好
所以你們看
所以沒有辦法
什麼事都有代價
所以想要折折的報酬
最好還是參加我會員
好不好
扯遠了
整個當好人好事代表
這麼忙還做這個事情
來
群聯跟世界
來啦 世界先進每天都要玩你嘛
我就問你 6488環球晶
展成這樣子你覺得世界先進
它漲價
不是說它很
它漲價一定是世界先進的需求很高
才漲價的
你懂嗎
理論上是這樣子
而不是說它
而不是說哇
它現在減少了供給或怎麼樣
所以世界先進這樣殺下去是沒有道理的
你們自己看一下聯電
它還在高漲震盪
聯電這樣漲你給我說世界先進會一直殺
拉回該買
就像你看今天
鴻海我覺得也到一個怎麼樣
止疊點的
鴻海營收也不錯喔
好不好 算同期新高
剛剛公佈五月營收
最近會公佈一些五月營收好不好
讓記憶體公佈五月營收
對 是好看一下
有沒有公佈誰營收了
趕快給我
趕快 趕快
或者朋友們來趕快考我
公佈營收
最好要給我月增
你不是給我個數字
不要動天才好不好
給我月營收那個
來個給我營收月增多少
好不好 月減多少
主委吃力不討好工作
對啊 吃力不討好
人怎麼辦
當初我就被人家要求
當了以後我就不後悔
不然我覺得大家都不
如果大家都不想做事的話
那我願意我做
那我希望別人來做事啊
摺層都沒有亮了
會不會台積電法說會利多出鏡
兩碼直視的
我管你有沒有亮
台積電法說這個大利多
基本上就會有亮了
OK嗎 好不好
今天肯定要買世界
還有今天要買世界
你看精彩也是很多人為什麼
有精彩的賺錢的舉手一下
會員或者粉絲好不好
精彩不是之前在給你這邊洗盤
你還不是一堆念我
你沒有洗盤怎麼賺錢啊
是不是
但懂不懂
精彩是洗盤啊
環球晶也是一樣啊
環球金洗更長耶
你看每一次都給你回答25%以上
沒錯吧
回答29%有沒有看到
有
你怎麼敢買啦
都是我破解說
這邊回答25%買耶
你看我們環球金賺多少
你自己看一下
所以你這邊拉回
我跟別人選的回答不一樣
第一個我讓你好近好出
我剛才講過了
譬如說我也不要再針對那個
因為我知道現在有人在講這個
譬如說Must be
來
或者是二級體這些的 有沒有
公立半導體
我唸給你聽
關於國具跟強茂對不對
一個市值兩兆
一個市值怎麼樣
不到1000億啦
是
你聽懂嗎
這跟大家講
那個國具
士尚你應該有寫錯了
國具跟強茂
股本不可能差那麼少
四雅你寫錯了啦
股本不可能差那麼多
四雅你再給我寫對數字一下
股本理論上 我邏輯上告我
我不可能差那麼多
因為價格他們沒有差很多
來
還是要分拆的關係
不管啦
一個市值不到1100
一個市值兩兆有沒有看到
市值差很多有沒有看到
市值差很多
到時候你會不好出
所以我選的股票就盡量有價有量
那你買得到
但你買得到
當然不是每檔啊
有些股票也是偶爾量少一點點
因為大型全資股
該買就買了
你看代表作怎麼樣
2454連發科
剛才有說過嘛
賺130幾%嘛 是不是
對
來來賺140幾% 130幾%嘛
所以都是一樣
那金財也是
金財也算比較小股本一點點
但我今天選大型全資股
你看環球金
全五大的全資股啊
上櫃指數前五大
從500多塊獎
每次回檔都家裡買
700塊
800塊
900塊
700塊又再一次
800塊一次
1000塊
這730敢買
1000塊又跌到730
你看我730家裡買
730家裡買第二次
有沒有看到
730買一次
730買第二次
有沒有看到
9個暫停
10個暫停
11個暫停
12個暫停
有沒有看到
對不起
13個展停 太多了
14個展停
你看上禮拜又拉到快展停 有沒有
那禮拜我偷拉尾盤
我以為被處置 他就不怕
今天要再給你展停 1380
我有沒有說過
為什麼我不要買國具
我說國際現在賺一倍很難
我說環球金有機會賺一倍
我就是要選環球金能賺一倍的股票
所以你看 恭喜6488環球金
一出關就直接噴展停
再穿利率新高
我們買金到現在最高已經獲利150%
我持續看好他
手上持股 獲利虛吧
有沒有看到
150%有沒有看到
是
是不是扯不扯
扯不扯
我還沒有走
現在很多老師也都跟你講賺100%
可是我是實實在在的
因為你看了這些股票
我從頭到尾講在前面
而且我不是說
傻很多碗
然後有展才講
不是喔
環球經費我是拉回去再講對不對
是
所以試驗現金
我有些股票拉回來再買
但只是說全中比重
我建議你還參加會員
你不要每次都聽我節目講
問題是你聽我節目
你覺得我會對會員比較好
還是對非會員比較好
肯定是會員就是會員嘛會員是我們的醫師父母嘛雖然現在財富自由但是會員嘛一定是我們的會員眾多我們才有什麼才有小安嘛
才有依依嘛
依依跟你們打招呼
大家好
小安來打招呼
哈囉
還有誰那個
那個莉莉嗎
我
還有韋汝
韋汝有麥克風嗎
他今天不在
資源資源資源
嚇死我
你看不然今天
不然旁邊都很多人
外面有金金跟四瑤一堆啦
是不是 危害什麼的一堆啦
都是一樣啦
還有台大政大的
然後會計師 分析師
我們團隊就這麼強嘛
是不是
所以標果一定比人家強
我們不是藝人團隊啊
我們比很多你看到的
基金技能的什麼
的什麼
的演藝團隊還強
很多基金技能是藝人團隊
是啊
有些老頭顧的分析師也是藝人團隊
跟你講說堅強的演藝團隊
一個人
我們不一樣
你去想一件事啦
你覺得誰的團隊比我多
火關粉絲就100多萬
你看就知道啦
是
一定服務的人比較多嘛
我怎麼可能只有一人而已啊
是不是
我有只有一個人
我不擔啦好不好
如果只有一個人
團隊我不擔啦
這個人讓人生太可憐了
你知道嗎
我不擔分析師啦
那可以嗎
所以要跟大家講
今天殺龍之盤
我今天是因為外資的
外資大幅的匯隊
大幅的匯出
好不好
環球星真的那時候
折第一個獎
那時1350萬
而且那時候你們有沒有看到
00981A
我不知道他很厲害
可是你看
巧富人為五米之吹
我在強調是
你看注意有人在動嗎
他沒在動有沒有看到
是
所以行情不好的時候他一樣
而且我跟你講
0050還是先創新高
近期0050要創新高有沒有知道
00981A還沒有咧對不對
對
00981那時候就把環球星
賣在五六百塊啊
是不是
你覺得沒錯的話
是不是 我那時候第一個講
而且他賣掉 我沒說什麼
是 我說我照買啊
精彩觀零股賺 生日說不是
零股你就可以賺
我覺得你資金你要20萬以內
你就當我的粉絲叫
不要當我會員
20萬以上
甚至你資金100萬 200萬以上
不差我會員說不過去好不好
聽哲哲 哲哲慢慢累積財富
謝謝大家
有跟金融有推哲的節目
你可能沒有人像我這樣良心事業
我還叫你不要融資
如果多叫你融資
說不定很多人參加我會員
我知道這種話不中聽
可是我不在乎啊
懂不懂
就像很多人說
哲哲你為什麼一定要捐救護車
也有人勸我啊
你知道也有家人朋友說
你不會學人家
你捐別的車子
捐一台100萬的車子
我不知道攻擊誰
是有人說這樣可以啊
我跟妳講
只要妳捐都是好
哲哲你為什麼不捐
捐個救護車捐一台500萬
人家覺得好像跟捐別的車一樣
別的車子捐100萬
一台抵人家5台
我說都是做善事沒有差
我想在上面寫個哲哲
而且我說捐救護車
因為什麼
我就想要捐個22台
我現在是人生第二台
我同學
我是有超過40歲了
不好意思
因為在投顧界已經快
已經20年了
所以那個差不多
我有生之年
基本上應該是可以捐22台以上
22台要1億
我就想要捐個超過1億
慢慢的累積
慢慢的累積捐錢
好不好
來鴻海公布營收
後來只要公布營收
有沒有比較新的營收
請世耀跟我們講
公布有沒有新的營收
數字是對的
沒事 好
來
來來來
那個
哲神 群聯還有Jill嗎
建議換股嗎
群聯好像漲不上去
可是群聯最近你知道嗎
他們董事那個執行長
他職位換人換去
潘董還在買群聯是不是
沒錯吧
他在買代表看得很好
美觀之前也是一樣
好不好
世界先進除息
所以你不要想那麼多
來 還有什麼
3481群串
還有 次元
我看一下 次元今天不應該跌
次元就低基期
好不好
他也沒漲
你也不要想他會跌
他是3萬點的股票
所以有些股票3萬點
現在為什麼很多人覺得股票難做
第一個 很多老師都習慣追高
我說盡量不要追高
不要說我都沒有
可是盡量我已經很少追高了
你懂嗎
第二個我選第一基期的股票
就算追高它是第一基期
是
比如精彩就算現在追
它大概也差不多
三四萬點精彩而已
你懂不懂
剛創新高
剛創歷史新高
你聽懂還說什麼吧
懂
所以我覺得這樣子
所以很多股票
你看我聯發科為什麼出掉
聯發科已經漲到七萬點去了
外資給你喊十四萬點的聯發科
喊一萬塊
那外資賣隔離
我覺得講話很慘
你怎麼知道TPU晶片
2027年聯發科不會被人家搶單
你聽懂嗎
我覺得就還好
我覺得還好
我覺得預測後年的事情
有點不太負責任
除非像台積電一樣
就是你在可見的未來
你的副成額
台積電在
你覺得在明年後年
台積電會被人家取代嗎
很難
因為技術不夠嘛
是
可是聯發科會被人家取代
當然啊
聯發科搶到的TPU晶片
你懂不懂
就像你搶人家女朋友
那接下來他還是可能會變心
你同樣的意思
你懂不懂
所以你搶人家的訂單
到最後怎麼樣
不好意思
人家也會把你搶回來
可是不一樣
台積電是靠真材實料的
所以我覺得就定價
那時候聯發科是很委屈
所以你看
我這個人是很理性的
在1000多元的時候
有沒有
都是1000多元
我說台積電會先漲
聯發科會後發先制
有沒有
不齒
你看那時候把台積電
換成聯發科
你愛死我
我轉三倍啊
可是現在我跟妳講
No No No No
那如果要比的話
我以前MFK現在賣掉
所以也還要換台積電
我的邏輯是非常清楚的
我不會因為我今天
我100萬粉絲
或者我股票轉一倍了
我開始碰碰大頭了
不是不是
我跟你講我都遇過這種多空頭
所以我跟你講
所以你去講那個聯發科
什麼什麼2027年
什麼EPS288元
從560元轉到288元
你這樣說這樣不幸福喔
不是他沒有一個技術屏佔
沒有那麼厲害
這是邏輯要很重要的
你懂不懂
它護城額沒那麼深
不像台積電你可以
我跟你講台積電每年營收增加20%以上
它是真的算得出來的
因為隨便它喊價你知道嗎
它算得出來的
可是聯發科不是
聯發科不能亂漲價
聯發科還會被人家砍價
你懂嗎
所以不是這樣算的
不是這樣算的
你說最後有沒有可能聯發科來市場去
有可能來籌碼站而已
這我去機率不高
我想走
所以我要買低基期股票
這樣understand
懂嗎
現在幾分了
差不多今天要結束了
所以再跟大家講
2408納尼科
納尼科算搶了一大堆
記憶體股票殺毀盤
他也算漲喔 好不好
那你說中美金怎麼看
我覺得沒怎麼看啊
我中美金我想買啊
很多會員在抱怨
中美金
你只有買過一次兩次而已啊
怎麼辦
拉回買嘛
我已經說過黃永金接下來
今天應該被警告
禮拜二禮拜三被警告
可能禮拜四就要
就要怎麼樣
就要被怎麼樣
就要被關了
所以二三可能會拉回
拉回你就
你看說中美金再拉回你就買嘛
就這麼簡單嘛好不好
剛才問2377維新
因為它又死掉了好不好
它又死掉是說它又不動
可是維新是不是跟那個一樣
跟什麼一樣
跟精彩一樣 什麼意思
你不要讓人看
只要再一根它就噴出去是不是
是不是再一根就噴出去
這是我畫的
再一根就噴出去
那再一根噴出去
我跟妳講是不是大家就想追了
妳懂不懂
這根很粗
呵呵呵
所以其實平常新好不好
這很多股票我都再一根就噴出去
6196帆薰也是一樣啊
今天看起來跌
它不是啊 它再一根就好了
它也不要太多
就這樣子就好
是不是你又想追了 放大放大
不行嘛 對
是不是再一根就噴出去是不是
是
一樣嘛 所以你就正面思考好不好
不是 我像很多股票一樣
世界先進也是一樣
好多股票
所以我最後跟大家講我們績效
看一下
這看一次只是最後的驗證的東西
來來
今天量算不錯
因為禮拜五 你要講一件事
禮拜五通常
禮拜五
美國獨立紀念日嘛 對不對
7月4號 休市嘛
所以休市它今天基本上沒有量
所以量有縮
真的有縮
但這個縮還是有一兆成交量
我可以接受 好不好
來看環球金從500 600 700
一展0百
730給你跌停桿買
730那一波展到現在
你看跌停桿買730
展到今天多少
光730買都快賺100%了
我沒有錯吧
沒錯
光730買都賺8 90%了
所以你看我最高已經獲利150%了
光730買
前生者你看730跌停板是不是很近的日子
上一次儲置的時候有沒有
跌停板對不對
所以就是一樣
不論什麼很多記憶體
或是有些股票拉回要買
但記憶體我現在打虧去mark
所以有些股票拉回要不要買
有些股票拉回不要買
你要找我啊
哪有分析師150%還沒走的啦
而且是實在在的
不是啊
突然有些分析師突然
你看我賺100%
環球金你都知道是我中壓股票啊
金才難道你也知道是我中壓股票
是不是嗎
是不是
跳功暫停啊
賺77%
77%算遜了
所以你去想看你要怎樣分析是好
你看而且我股票跌我都敢講
是不是
不會這樣
不見了
我又不是魔術師
你要激動就ok
我很激動啊
所以你看金才賺77%
還算遜的咧
環球金賺150%
150%
光是跌停板那天買進的股票
跌停板買進的股票有沒有
現在快1400了
有沒有
730元挂跌停板的股票
都已經賺100%了
才一個月的時間賺80% 90%
有沒有看到
是不是
是
跌停板買
想買就買
所以現在還是中年期
現在外資落跑
台幣貶值
賞物的資金被壓抑
在等待什麼
萬事俱備
只欠通風
碰
糊了
等另外一件事
不只是精彩
今天展廳
等台積電的資本支出概念
等台積電的營收
我已經告訴他會怎麼說了
營收有沒有可能超過4成
我覺得有可能
不論對臥挫 哲哲
一切一切預告前面
到時候台積電
到時候就
從這個怎麼樣利多
台積電股市就會
突破5萬點
這是有機會
你要趕快搶先布局
不是 哲哲你好厲害
少買股票有什麼厲害
我厲害你不開心幹嘛
一起開心好不好
好
你就趕快參加我們行列
歡迎來電視頻
080-66-808
或叫LINE私訊我
不論對臥挫 哲哲
一切一切預告前面
去想看你要怎麼回事
也预祝各位能够赚大钱
恭喜我们环球青
你们看到赚了150%还没走
去想想看你要怎样分析师
也预祝各位真的财富翻倍
拜拜
投資人因獨立判斷、審慎評估,並自負投資風險
谢谢大家